bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you we have an exciting
show for you today
here on the Deen show a former tour
manager for some of the most famous
celebrities out there in the world and
he's here on the Deen show to give us
some of the insight on what really goes
on behind the scenes so you don't want
to miss this show here on the Deen show
George Green we'll be right back this is
the team the deegeu this is the thing is
the thing
this is the video this is the thing is
the theme is with me you know this is
the thing is that angel
this is the video this is we're back
here on a Dean Shawn with us former tour
manager for some of the most famous
celebrities in the world George Green
welcome to the Dean show assalamu
alaikum peace be with you
walaikum Salam how are you my brother
I'm Delisle I'm doing well thank you
George Green tell us a little bit about
your history and the work you used to do
with people such as jay-z 50 and the
likes of I've had the opportunity to
work for jay-z at his multi-million
dollar record label Rockefeller Records
for about six to eight years I am I
started off as an intern before actually
working for jay-z and once hired in and
got the opportunity I started off as a
doing marketing branding and promotions
that I let in to tour management what
were some of the other famous
celebrities that you worked with in the
past before coming to Islam I've worked
for 50 cent I've worked for Kanye West
I've worked for
I've worked with Snoop I've worked with
Jim Jones Cam'ron I've worked with the
countless a list artist that the list is
is extremely long
so many too many to name actually tell
us what attracted you to this lifestyle
well the lifestyle is welcoming the
lifestyle it's appealing to young some
sometime older older mature people as
well I mean the cars to jewellery the
women the money the the just the extreme
lifestyle of looking like you have no
problems and you are just in a
comfortable appealing lifestyle George
Wayne tell us being around all these
celebrities all these famous people can
you tell us what was the day-to-day
lifestyle of a celebrity like well the
day-to-day lifestyle consisted of drugs
women alcohol partying and just count
countless traveling just know numerous
hours of traveling tour bus planes and
lots of partying lots of partying now
here's a crucial question were you happy
I personally was not happy I was just
looking for something that I never was
able to find I had no substance I was
looking for women daily drugs daily just
just just constant things that never
make me feel complete as a person I
never found that sense of complete list
completeness I never found the
opportunity to feel whole and just
[Music]
feeling like I was able to find myself I
was constantly chasing the same thing
the short-term happiness in the short
term fulfilment never found what I was
looking for until I found a
George along with working for some of
the most famous people in the world
these celebrities that you mentioned did
you get a chance to hang out with them
while you weren't working on a regular
basis yes I was actually I talked with
them everywhere they went from city to
city country to country most of the time
we just toured performed in our shows
whatever country or city we were in and
most people not naming any names
everyone went afterwards resort to women
the drugs the alcohol the short-term
fulfillment it's all a fantasy it's a
fantasy of short-term happiness
short-term fun and you just repeat it
over and over and over daily now George
tell us when did you get exposed to
Islam well I was exposed to Islam about
five six years ago traveling abroad I
was exposed to the Middle East and once
I was in this in the Middle East I got a
chance to see its Lomb from a different
perspective because growing up and
seeing a lot of Muslims I wasn't really
exposed to a lot of practicing Muslims
and I was exposed to the American media
which didn't portray a really the best
example of a Muslim so going to the
Middle East allowed me a chance to see
Islam from a different perspective and I
saw how welcoming people were towards
Islam I saw the unity and I saw the
brother and sisterhood and I saw the
everyone were unified as to how they
went to pray and everyone was unified
into doing things by Islam and I was
just impressed by that and I started to
take an interest and started to study
and read and ask questions to active
practicing Muslims and Saleh you know
masha'Allah I'm now here a Muslim and I
am I was able to basically find out for
myself the truth of Islam and I just
took an interest and I took my shotta
and here I
now a Muslim George won was the turning
point in your life where you finally
realized that Islam submission with
Islam is simply an Arabic word which
means submission to the will of God when
did you realize that this was indeed the
truth revealed from the Creator not a
man-made religion organized by man or
men but indeed it was from the crater
that happens in earth when you finally
realizes well I was always searching for
I never once claimed a religion and I
was always searching I always believed
in God I always believed in a higher
power but I never could really find what
I wanted through Christianity or any of
these other things so I just had a I
woke up one day and and just started to
research about the the holy books I
started to find out more about the Holy
Quran about how the integrity of Islam
was protected for over a thousand years
I started to find out more about the
Prophet Muhammad may peace be upon him
and I was convinced that Islam was the
correct way I was convinced that our law
was the only way and I was convinced
that it was time for me to become a
Muslim yours tell us how has its Lama
improved your life
um Islam has improved my life in several
areas it has allowed me to become more
patient it has allowed me to see life in
a broader perspective become a better
man not live a worldly temptation
lifestyle and it has allowed me to be
more
responsible as a man and as one with my
relationship with Allah and it'll it has
allowed me to just be more less tempting
and more responsible as a person is
allowed me to be step away from worldly
temptations and continue to acts a lot
to guide me continue to give me more
patience and it is just strengthened my
relationship with the law in many ways
before Islam came into my life let's go
back in history just a little bit more
did you ever wrap yourself I was more
hired help never wrapped never was an
artist I was always hired help I was
always the person responsible for
helping the artist to be successful on
tour I'm responsible for helping them to
have what they need on stage dressing
rooms helping them to be punctual
helping them be detailed on tour things
like that George tell us now you've got
to spend a lot of time with some of the
most famous people famous celebrities
people that are out there people are
idolizing them you got to spend time
with them now you are behind the scenes
tell us did you see them as truly being
happy truly having peace and contentment
in life well I can't really speak for
people but I know myself most of these
people are live in lifestyles and it's
all smoking mirrors it's our imagery on
I don't want to speak for anyone but I'm
sure that these people are not
completely happy with this lifestyle
because this lifestyle brings along
other things it brings along violence it
brings along more temptation it brings
along it welcomes lots of issues and I'm
sure that it's a very stressful
lifestyle when you have to portray a
certain image in the public's eye and
then when you are rapping or singing
about this lifestyle you have to live it
as well and I'm sure this is not the
easiest thing to do George tell us has
it been challenging being a new Muslim
it's been very challenging being a new
Muslim I deal with multiple challenges I
deal with a lot of worldly challenges
that I have you know been asking a lot
to continue to remove me from that it's
a lot of cultural challenges deal with a
lot of just other Muslims interested in
you changing overnight other Muslims
being a little rough on you everything
you do is considered haram and it's
tough but it's and it's always the
worldly temptations are always seem to
be more welcoming now that you are
closer to a lot these things become more
welcoming more women come your way more
worldly temptations come your way and
it's just a challenge to try to stay
away from these things and it seems the
more you get closer to Allah the more
worldly temptations come into your life
or try to come into your life because
Allah has been doing a great job with
keeping me focused keeping me
away from these things and helping me
get to a better place
we'll be right back
what is close to death that's all God
don't let me die but he's got something
better than this world what's God going
to get out of punishing you anyway
you have to connect to this
understanding that the Quran is from God
that Muhammad is His Messenger and the
answers to the problems in our life are
there and if we're going to worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the Creator instead of any of
the creations I'm not afraid I am not
afraid to stand alone if Allah is by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if iliza
I am Not Afraid to stay
[Music]
George moving along we have a few more
questions for you tell us how did the
men in this business view women tell us
about that well again I can only speak
for myself but I personally would look
for women as sexual desires at the time
I would try to conquer as many women as
I could sexually at the time I would be
disrespectful with language I would be
disrespectful with my actions and now
I'm in a place where I recognize that
this is totally wrong this is totally
the wrong I wouldn't want to have anyone
speak to my daughter if inshallah allow
us to bless me with a daughter one day I
wouldn't want anyone to view my my
mother or my grandmother in any kind of
disrespectful manner I wouldn't want to
have any one woman wise and my family to
walk around half dressed or being
belittled or whistled or derogatory
statements spoken to them so I decided
to change my way of thinking about women
stop with the sexual desires and lusting
and temptation and I just realized that
this was the incorrect way of being and
I was taught this way for so many years
that it had became a part of my everyday
lifestyle George tell us what advice do
you have for those people out there who
are inspiring to be like these
celebrities these people who used to
want to be like before Islam tell us
well my advice would be to understand
that this is a lifestyle of no return
this is a lifestyle that has no
fulfillment it's a constant chase every
day for the same thing you're chasing
the women the money the cars the light
you're chasing the lifestyle and you
still never find that completeness and
that fulfillment fulfilling this so my
advice would be to seek Allah and to
these worldly temptations are they take
you nowhere they just take you to a
short term happiness short term
fulfilling this and it doesn't it's a
short term short term fulfillment and
short term happiness and once you seek
Allah Allah provides you with that void
that you've been missing such as myself
Allah provides you with that that
happiness Allah provides you with the
the all the tools and all of the
survival tactics and survival kits that
you need to complete the happiness when
it comes to women when it comes to
financial things when it comes to any of
these kind of things Allah the provided
I can say so because I am a living
testament and a living example of this
lifestyle and I have seeked Allah I
found a lot and now I am happy and those
voids have been fulfilled by George tell
us couple more questions has it been a
challenging establishing some of the
tenets of Islam the five daily prayers
you know seeking knowledge because Islam
stimulates the mind and the more you
study the more you convince that this is
indeed the truth and it's a way of life
that requires some discipline has it
been challenging well it's all a
challenge to start but you know I
continuously acts Allah to make it easy
for me because I come many many years my
entire life I've lived this lifestyle so
now becoming a new Muslim it's it is a
challenge it is constant work it's
constant prayer and I do the best that I
can
as continuously keeping my faith and I'm
constantly tested every day and I have
done an incredibly remarkable job thus
far as a
new Muslim and it's not easy it's not
easy at all but mashallah doing the best
that I can
George tell us with many of the
challenges that you've had now looking
back do you have any regrets with the
decision that you've made to become a
Muslim one who has submitted himself
entirely to the one creator well I don't
necessarily say that I have regrets I
will say that living that worldly
lifestyle with public figures and music
it did allow me to see the world
something that I would have not have
been able to do if I wasn't allowed this
opportunity it's allowed me to go to
almost 50 countries I've been to almost
all 50 states I've been an outer box
thinker it's allowed me to discover
Islam it's allowed me to be more global
as my way of thinking but it also
provided me with a tempting lifestyle
and with a you know Haram lifestyle but
I don't think I would ever take it back
or go back to it if I was offered the
opportunity now being a Muslim I'm happy
and more in concern about my salvation
my relationship with Allah and I think
that everyone who experiences this
lifestyle should just consider picking
up the Quran speaking to Muslims and
finding out about Islam and
understanding that that lifestyle is a
long journey to destruction great having
you on the show on the Deen show thank
you very much George thank you so much I
said on while they can peace be with you
my alaikum salam' working for some of
the most famous individuals out there in
the world and he woke up I'm ecstatic to
see people waking up realizing that you
know what that's the wrong way as he
said let's learn a lesson from his life
that that way of life is a road to
destruction now why you want to go down
a road that's the road to destruction
when you see people living in
egocentric life narcissists just full of
themselves just consuming and as you can
see in some of the pictures all about
the bling-bling baby cars rides not
thinking about the soul there's more to
life there's more to life than fill in
your belly driving a Bentley rolling
around in a Rolls Royce getting all the
ladies in the woman and the woman
there's more to your life than just
being a material possession and chasing
a man with money there's more to these
things than the reality TV shows Jersey
Shore's
MTV Nate nighttime daytime drama we have
to wake up and that brother woke up and
these shows that we put on are supposed
to be for us to benefit from their
experiences because if somebody already
went down a one-way street you don't
have to go down that one-way street also
there is a purpose to life he realized
what it was
so we really want people to ponder and
think contemplate are you really happy
do you really have true peace and
contentment in life many of those people
as he said it's a facade from the
outside it's all smiles because who
doesn't smile for the camera but when
the lights are on the party's over and
then what they're having to deal with
themselves and they've been corrupting
themselves corrupting their bodies so
God Almighty has sent the guidance
throughout time and it's simple to
understand Islam is not something
dubious unclear hazy it's really
straightforward that there's one creator
he created you he's the one that feeds
you he's the one that takes care of you
and he loves you he loves you that's
right so no matter what you've done in
the past start fresh today a new page a
new beginning and reach out to the one
who created you and ask him for guidance
God loves you has given you everything
that you have don't you love the Creator
so ask him for guidance
sincerely earnestly want it
and then start to really weigh out
what's more important some of these
things that I'm doing from day to day
the partying the drinking getting drunk
smoking weed
dope chasing woman the woman chasing the
man fashion magazines wasting time
wasting time and at the end we die and
then we wake up then the rowdy kicks in
oh my god it's over and then you didn't
prepare for the ultimate reality death
that's right and then the day of
judgment and we have to decide now are
we going to be people of the Hellfire or
people of the Paradise and God Almighty
he don't get nothing out of punishing us
he wants the best for us that's why he
warned people about the day of judgment
and the Hellfire he sent messengers and
it's been very straightforward illusive
message worship the unseen supreme being
the one who created you as soon as
religion gets mystical and weird and
bizarre then it's a red light here it's
hold up
that's a man-made philosophy ideology
but the ideology the way of life that's
lucid clear understandable no ambiguity
in it it's straightforward is that way
that's been there since the beginning
since the first man submit yourself
entirely to the one God the one Supreme
Being no operators no secretary direct
dial up God doesn't have sons or
daughters he doesn't do these
animalistic things that we do as human
beings no don't insult God don't insult
God there's a passage from the Bible and
joke it says what is man but a maggot
this is in the Bible and what is the son
of man the son of man is worm
so when you see compared to God respects
what are we instead of saying glory be
to God we insult God by bringing him
down to the level of a human being
you wouldn't want mercy from a judge and
called the judge say hey son of a monkey
could you forgive me no you wouldn't
like it if somebody called you a maggot
would you what about calling the Creator
bringing him down to the level of a
human being and insulting him many of us
been programmed that God had a son that
he died no God doesn't die Jesus prayed
the one God Jesus submitted to the one
God Jesus was a Muslim just like George
Green accepted Islam submission to the
one God he's a Muslim now he's chosen
not to submit to Mohammed or to the Sun
or the moon he decided to submit to the
one who created Jesus the one who
created Moses the one who created you me
and everything in his universe and
that's where it begins with oh I can
just keep talking it's exciting because
it's simple to understand Islam means
submission look at the word submission
not to yourself not to your desires not
to anyone or anything but submission to
the one who created you is he not worthy
of praise and thanks he gave you
everything
so thank him call upon him establish a
relationship with him forget about the
past because when you accept Islam all
your previous sins they're eradicated
they're erased you have a new beginning
so it's a call to action look into the
connaissez of your first time view in
the show it's the verbatim Word of God
unchanged tamper free tamper-proof it's
the way of life that was sent down by
the Creator throughout time one religion
because there's one recipient me and you
the human beings so it's one message
worship the one unseen crater and don't
worship His creation and obey the
messenger that was sent and Muhammad is
the last and final messenger accepting
him you accept Jesus Moses Abraham all
the other messages that came and they
all came with the same message do God's
will not your desires and if you've been
watching the shows or even if it's your
first time you're like this is it it
makes sense and I'm ready to change
because def can hit you when you turn
the channel you can walk on the street
and then what what do you got so you
have to be on the right way in that
right way is the way that God Almighty
sit down submission to his will call the
number on their screen and make that
first step
acknowledge that there is a creative
there's no god but the one God and
Arabic we say Allah in Aramaic jesus
said aloha so it's not some foreign God
some whom God no it's the one creator
that gives you the eyes that you see
with the heart that you love with the
air that you breathe is he not worthy of
thanks and that's where it starts with
being thankful and grateful
one that wants the truth because when
you want it is there now you got to
decide am I going to continue to live a
life of debauchery just tasting my wins
and desires and then I die and I lose
this world because we're all going to
die and then I lose paradise the next
life and what's waiting for me then a
hot place don't end up being tricked and
fooled by the satanic forces work hard
to be the best human being that you can
be and the only way you can do that is
by acknowledging that I have a creator
and I'm ready to worship it I'm going to
follow the brute print that was set down
throughout time and that's in the Quran
verbatim word of God so much more to
cover but start with this first step
call us call us
tell them you watch the Deen show and
you're ready to be one who has submitted
to the will of God like George Green and
over 1.5 billion people out there in the
world today salam says love all mankind
that's why we're sharing this message
because we want the best for you and we
want the best for all mankind
we'll see you next time God willing on
the Deen show continue to tune in peace
be unto you